[Music]
and good karma news submitted by mochi
ice cream oh that's delicious
a stranger helped a woman down on her
luck years later she repaid the favor
with the [ __ ] giving [ __ ] is bad
now I'm still waiting for my karma I do
good deeds not to expect things back but
I'm just saying that I'm never guy who's
just saying you want some [ __ ] back just
saying it'll be nice by now if the
spirits kind of bless me the universe
doesn't agree that you're doing good so
well I got to do more gooder stuff you
got to do a truly selfless act no one
truly selfless acts really selfless it's
selfless it's just you know I'm just
saying it would be nice if the universe
kind of leveled them we should touch I
should test your morality right now
would you kick a puppy in the face for
70 million dollars yes yes or as Roger
was in or it's so funny like when I ask
these group of people's the ends are so
fast I ask somebody like another group
of people they look at me like I was a
monster III will suck a dick I will not
kick a puppy Oh hundred million dollars
how many puppies how many puppies did
you save with a hundred million dollars
that's true it's all about you have to
kill it or just kick it who knows who
knows what happens to it you but you're
gonna have to kick it until it's dead
that's a lot of money
I want my money's worth I want my
entertainment you're a monster okay take
it back I feel gross now I've seen a
video where someone did that and it's
trouble dramatizing I'm kidding you
[ __ ] out puppy I'm commenting on hate
comment right now on you it's Steve Appa
JK news this Steve guy would kick a
puppy for money I used to like him put
that on a troll cake yeah so anyways
I'll do it you care about money too when
you're out of your [ __ ] parents house
dude yes sir you'll see yeah so three
years ago there was this woman named ton
D yes her name is 10 D mmm
keep it together keep it together ton D
ton D I don't know why but I started
thinking of Crocodile Dundee
I thought punty or some [ __ ]
Jamaican version of Gandhi yeah yeah
[Laughter]
so ton D her car broke down she ran out
of gas you only had $5 in her pocket how
irresponsible she was down on her luck
[Laughter]
it was pouring rain at the same time so
no umbrella either they didn't mention
that part I'm assuming though so then
she had a long walk ahead of her to go
get gas and and so there was that same
day that's when this man named Chris he
was driving his with his family to
church when he saw ton D walking along
the side of the road and so he kept
driving he dropped off his wife and told
her that he'd be right back and so
that's when he turned around and then
went to go pick up ton D because he just
felt compelled to go pick her up
and so he filled her she got in the car
with him mm-hmm
she he filled up her her empty gas can
and then handed her all the cash that he
had in his wallet and then they parted
ways
so then three years later Toto what
that's really nice and all but if it was
raining and I was walking out in the
rain alone in
pulled up and asked me if I want to get
in a car I would say [ __ ] no yeah you
wouldn't get in the car if especially if
I needed help but if he smiled and then
he looks like he was kind of okay but
what if he felt insulted by that like I
was gonna give you all my money now I'm
gonna kill you oh well at least I'm not
in the car could still run yeah yeah in
the car I know what if he was holding
like a really big shiny lollipop yeah
I'll do it yeah you get that yes he says
shiny it's the carnival one so years
later that's when Chris's mother she was
really ill she has parking just
Parkinson's disease and then that's when
and for him being started going downhill
really quickly so the family brought in
a nursing staff to take care of his
mother named Judy and then that's when
they were told that she only had a few
weeks to live but there was a one nurse
aide in particular that grew really
close to Judy and so they're saying that
she cared for her and like the most
respectful way she had the utmost
respect for human life and amongst their
talks it was brought up how one day
tündi which is a nurse's aide she was
down on her luck and then someone helped
her with the gas and that's when they
discovered that it was Judy Sun that did
all this yes no they were like wow like
it was just it was crazy so then she
grew really close to this family and
then eventually the family decided to
create a YouCaring page so like took
crowdfund
enough money for tündi to go to school
and to become a nurse because she was
only a nurse nurses aide at that point
so I'm gonna show you guys a video clip
of time Dee's reaction wait so this
family helps her twice yeah exactly it's
not like she repaid the favor they just
helped her again well the thing is
they're saying that she repaid by taking
care of care of their mom but she was
was her job well I guess the way that's
the coolest thing I've heard today
saying that the headline is kind of
clickbait because I'm like you should be
paying Nicky's Nicky's a person who
throws trash in the ground pick it up
that's your [ __ ] job
I do not litter that was really sweet
well she did it for free cuz nurses like
darn they charge a lot of money right
nurse practitioner whatever it could be
expensive so she [ __ ] you no no nurses
nurse's aide is like uncertified right
but she became a real sleep on the couch
I swear in two schools
lucky today up yeah well she was a nurse
in there at that point so yeah she was
hired to be there I get a day bit
talking about a bit quick yes so then
anyway the family says that they don't
believe in coincidences and so they're
saying that they're a family of faith
and that they believe that God brought
them together tündi and my family yeah
and so that's when they came up with the
with the page and in order to come up
with money for it send me to go back to
school so I'm gonna show you guys it was
the Sun dating her now I feel like they
should get married now that's how the
movie goes know ah here we go
Chris is the guy that gave her gas money
yeah the son of juice
they just keep helping her to cover my
expenses that's why so Chris is dead
whoa it's Judy still life no she's but
they're saying that tündi was really
nice to her like she went the extra mile
yeah that's pretty cool she's doing her
job
why does this remind me of that movie I
just made you're like Nikki at a target
just destroy everything there's no job
right so just she destroys a whole
display at a grocery store pick it up
farm boy something and everyone's mr.
words right now I feel your spirit
through the seat cushion you bring like
200 items to the freakin changing room
dude she's like no cup holder damn it
I'm making work for you she cried
without me there would be no job I hate
you don't touch me so anyway so the
YouCaring page initially their goal was
$1,000 as of right now it's $36,000 so
the goal was a thousand yeah it was
thirty six thousand almost thirty seven
dollars Oh
yeah machining for school a thousand
body was [ __ ] school a cheap no to give
her a gift but then it wound up sorry
went viral so then a lot of people are
donating as right now she's about
nursing school yes she could be a
registered nurse yes okay because
there's like LVN DNA DNA
Elvia yeah or in our BSN and then yes
36k like won't even cover rappin BSN
sounds like a [ __ ] but a paper like
the first dude that's it yeah so
congrats congrats tündi you know what i
thought was gonna happen but it is she's
a really good person she really is
here's that here's what i thought was
gonna have the weak moment with picking
up farm boy i got a better story alright
I gave her the money but gas money [ __ ]
so the okay so here's a better story
okay so he helped her out gave her some
gas money she became a billionaire came
back and said remember that moment you
hope that's what I was looking for ten
million dollars right and then they get
married and again and he leaves his wife
and marries her that's beautiful for oh
yeah so my career story but that's her
job
[Music]
hey you know what roll back the tape is
gonna hate me forever
help help Nikki out editor and roll back
the tape that was her job but she was
pink when she was but she was pink when
she was
we expect that out of them all right
taking care of a dying woman that's not
the extra thing but she took care of
other bad woman so it's her job is what
you're supposed to be the power Abdul
show okay nice animal encouraging with
no fingers all palm stain your leg
yeah that's my job hey you guys want to
stock any of us we'll go ahead down to
the description box below and you can
follow us on Instagram and all kinds of
stuff for more videos
[Music]